I would like to actually thank all those
of you who took the time to listen to me
and to give me some of your insights and
some of your answers and I I totally
agree we have to solve the political
issues and we have to strengthen
partnerships on the other side now like
actually to commence to comment on mr.
David's answer and about the role of
Education of religious and cultural
education in the US and in the Muslim
and I would like to ask him do you think
there is actually one clear definition
on one what kind of contact we content
we can actually deliver to younger
generations in the region in the US and
in the middle east and north africa do
you think there is actually clear
definition of what content exactly will
be able to change the dynamics of the
relationship and do you think actually
that school books can change the
dynamics of the relationship towards the
direction that we wanted to that we want
a direction of mutual understanding and
coming around between the u.s. and the
Muslim